we cannot just eat people is there
something you might own
with my eyes cooperate
and you just might survive
how are you doing Eddie you look
terrible Oh what's up everyone another
awesome venom trailer like I said before
since it's so close to coming out in
theaters the promotion for it is just
going to go through the roof to get
everybody super hyped for it and I think
this trailer did a really good job at
that it's got a few scenes that are
awesome so it starts off with Eddie
Brock saying we cannot just eat people
of course
venom says we can do whatever we want
and then we have this scene right here
where there's a SWAT team and they all
have their laser sights pointed on Eddie
Brock in which the symbiote takes over
then you just see venom leap through the
air jump on one of the SWAT team members
hold him high up in the air and it looks
like he eats him we see his mouth
basically unhinged it open super wide
tongue flies out flailing around true
venom fashion and then the scene cuts
but I think it's most likely that he ate
him especially since this trailer starts
off with him saying we cannot just eat
people so that clearly means he eats
somebody in the movie probably more than
one person now this is a really good
indicator that they're going to do their
best with this movie to stick to Venom's
true nature in the comics especially
people that were really worried after
they heard that venom is rated pg-13
they were worried that we weren't going
to see some of the stuff like venom
eating people and then we even have this
other scene where the cashier lady says
how you doing Eddie you look terrible
and it cuts to a scene where it looks
like venom eats another person and this
person doesn't look like they're on the
SWAT team so I think this is a different
scene so although this trailer is short
it's only 30 seconds long I think it
does bring some ease to some people who
thought we weren't going to really get a
good venom movie and that venom wouldn't
be eating people in it but this trailer
makes it pretty apparent that we're
gonna see it happen the fact that it's
pg-13 I don't think makes a huge
difference I think we're going to see a
good venom movie that sticks true to who
the character is but let me know what
you all think and let me know how
excited you are to see venom when it
in just a few weeks and just a reminder
about the giveaway I'm doing I'm giving
away a copy of Avengers infinity war a
special edition poster and some special
memorabilia from our partners silk and
cotton all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber like this video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero thank you all so much
for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you